I have a little announcement to make all
right go ahead if it's good it's gonna
be something stupid I've got a feeling
I'm gonna guess the announcement you
have a boyfriend and you're in love I'm
gonna shave your head all right what is
the announcement go ahead all right
she's got a real goofy smile on her face
you're getting your period getting a new
cat no I really got you took a new
picture of yourself that you're hanging
on the wall you're moving to another
country I go ahead what is your
announcement please yes that from this
moment on are you gonna be Robin and
you're dropping nope I am now friendly
princess turn on taxi did you change
your name to it and I'm going by three
names from now on okay all right well
that's okay that's right Robin Ophelia
cookie is that right yes wait what are
you talking about oh you're making a
joke what do you mean you're doing it
I'm gonna be three names you've got too
much free time you say you're busy but
you're really not what do you mean how
are you gonna do this well from now on
when you refer to me it's not Robin
Quivers it's Robin Ophelia Quivers yeah
good luck with that I know where are you
going like in other words how is the
public going to become familiar with
this well if you see my name imprint
that's the way it'll be that's so she
doesn't get confused with all the other
Robin Quivers right cuz there's so many
others you might be getting carried away
with you just might
Red Robin will fill your quiver you want
people to really stop and think about it
good luck hey if that makes you happy
good I wonder what else you're thinking
about doing and when you sign your name
now if someone asked for an autograph it
will be rock and Celia Quivers when did
it why don't you talk about when it came
to you this name just last night you
should you really feel comfortable
announcing this
I mean maybe you'll change tonight
constantly tell people no it's Robin
Ophelia Quivers so when someone says to
you hi I'm hey Robin Quivers I'll say
Robin Ophelia Quivers right you'll have
to retrain your cats well good for you
isn't that exciting I mean I don't talk
to talk about it talk about your name
change and how it'll occur I've always
used the oh in my name in my personal
life that's true I happen to know that
Robin Oh Quivers of people that you're
Irish any of that confusion right
embracing your full identity
I've always used the Oh everybody's
going to these three name things now
who's everybody
you know Kimberly Amber Thiessen or
whatever the highfalutin name people
with three names usually are considered
more intelligent more credible more
there is a certain there is a certain
truth to that when you hear Robin
Ophelia Quivers then it gives me more
credibility to sit here and be the voice
of sanity
oh very good listen I'm into it I don't
even know why you're keeping Robin
Ophelia Quivers why not just chuck that
name and go - you know Kourtney Quivers
or Christie equivalent or princess I'll
feel your make make a real statement
change your name if I get people used to
the Robin Ophelia maybe I could just
drop the Robin you want to drop Robin I
want to have a weird
name I'll feel your Corbin so now
instead of hating Ophelia you love it
yeah because it's different nobody's a
fee if there's too many Robins
right you know what it doesn't affect me
your name change cuz I just call you
Robin anyway Robin Ophelia ya know
oh I see the Robin goes with Robin
Ophelia oh well I am NOT doing that you
know what you you know what if you if
you are gonna do a name change you need
me to go into it with you we cannot sit
here and have you call her what's new in
the news Robin don't feel you anything
okay I'm talking to you you lady you
Robin Ophelia okay yeah I'll try
I feel stupid doing it I'm the one who's
got it you know you change your name I
know one who's got to do it not you